do you all know the legend of ligma and
Johnson
ligma and Johnson were two individuals
who went to Twitter HQ and walked out
carrying boxes and then started telling
reporters that they had been fired and
their names were like Rahul ligman like
Daniel Johnson or something get it ligma
Johnson and so uh the media got hoaxed
Elon Musk invited them back in to the
actually I think I have the Tweet right
here is it right here yeah Elon Musk
invited them back to Twitter HQ saying
welcoming back ligma and Johnson
and then uh this is a clip from the
hills Rising please listen I mean what
do you think this is about is it because
he has created such a poor working
environment has ruined the relationship
between him and his employees so much
that he's not able to do the job because
I saw him he was tweeting out pictures
of him standing with two employees who
had fired
prematurely and then rehires his arms
around them kind of like hey I know I I
shouldn't admit to my mistakes it seems
like he's in a desperate situation where
he's realizing he actually needs
somebody and the single genius myth is
just that a myth and he actually needs
these employees to work for him and the
employees didn't look so happy in that
photograph I gotta say I mean I don't
know what this is Robbie Robbie what did
how how Daniel one of the hoaxsters says
how are we still tricking journalists
how is this still happening
yeah he's like I'm not sure Harry
belzania was also
and she's
awesome
she's also just saying like fired early
who's writing it and doesn't know that
this is amazing I love how condescending
she is she's like we he thinks he's a
genius look how stupid he is yeah and
the hills like well I feel worse all of
it the hill the hill Rising used to be
crystal in uh uh Sagar right and now
it's uh Brianna Joy gray and Robbie
Suave I feel like these individuals
probably don't read
like no and that's the problem with a
lot of the media and a lot of these
journalists now is they're not really
journalists they're like commentators on
you know what's hot and commentating on
this this photo that Elon Musk posted
it's like very pop culturally it's not
actual news she said she saw the photo
okay right yeah she said that yeah the
photo says ligma and Johnson on it
yes so she read that and then said it
went over her head you know the poor
woman Johnson come on this is a
family-friendly show here what do you
mean Tim what are you trying to say here
I'm trying to say that uh 12 year olds
are the ones who are pushing this joke
yeah literally
maybe that's I went over her head but
like she bought a hook line and stinker
yeah
this is the the modern State yes sorry
that's embarrassing this is the modern
state of media I guess
this is sad it's sad yeah and she did a
whole piece on it she was so proud of
herself too she was so emboldened have
they apologized she woke up and read
that and she's like what an idiot
this ligma Johnson guy
that didn't look happy in the photo yeah
the I think who's that is this ligma
that's ligma that's ligma uh does it say
legmon actually he he looks like a ligma
yeah yeah Johnson yeah Daniel he's got
name tags Rahul and Daniel and that's uh
Rahul ligma and Daniel Johnson he
doesn't Johnson doesn't sound right no
right yeah it doesn't or who ligma seems
Raul ligma legmon Johnson the media got
hoaxed the first time Elon this is the
this is the craziest thing it's like the
people who like what Elon Musk is doing
understand the memes the jokes the
laughing
I don't get it right we talk about Nancy
Pelosi we talk about Hunter Biden the
laptop we know all of these things how I
don't how do we know these things and
okay you know what I'm going to stress
this point
the left and the right is not political
at all it is knowledge and ignorance if
you are stupid and not paying attention
you'll find yourself on the left if you
are interested and inquisitive you'll
find yourself on the right and I'm not
saying that if you're inquisitive all of
a sudden you're like I'm pro-life no you
you might end up being someone who's
like actually I'm pro-choice but yeah
Biden's crooked not your right wing now
I'm still laughing because this is not
the first time the corporate Media made
such mistakes and again we have to
remember according to YouTube these are
the authoritative sources we got to
believe them no matter what we gotta
Elevate them over everyone else do you
remember the the something Wong
airplane crash that happens
literally on Asian flight 214 that
literally went down we had KTVU a local
news broadcast go on national television
and say that the four Pilots or all of
those names in unison right there so so
yeah this should be a a big reality
check to a lot of people especially to
the you know the fact Checkers that that
again the corporate media gets it wrong
they get it wrong a lot a lot of people
make mistakes but they're never really
held accountable for it but at least we
can laugh at them so at least we still
got that I was watching the FTX
commercial with Larry David have you
guys seen it no you know with all the
news on FTX going on I started like
digging into it and I watched the
commercial with Larry David and it's uh
basically it goes back to ancient times
as a guy with a wheel and Larry David
standing there is like what is it and
he's like it's a wheel he's like what
does it do and he's like it rolls so
does a bagel it's stupid then it shows
him like in with like a woman and she's
like pouring it she's like it's coffee
and he drinks it oh it's terrible and
like the gag was he was against all good
things and then one of the scenes is
he's with the founding fathers and then
they're like they have the Declaration
of Independence and he goes what do you
mean everyone gets to vote and they're
like yes everyone goes even the stupid
people and they're like yes he goes no
and he tries to rip up the Declaration
of Independence but uh that was the one
moment where I was like well I don't
agree with tearing up the Declaration of
Independence certainly but he brings up
a good point about stupid people voting
it is a problem and it needs to be
addressed somehow
no it absolutely is true it's true it's
gotten us here yeah maybe just has to go
back to the landowning men I'm sorry to
say I think it's when we started letting
women vote that things South well women
can own land the ladies that's right
yeah we have a sponsor that allows uh in
one foot and you're you're a lady of
Scotland yeah and uh then you get to
vote because you own land what kind of
property rights do I have to it though
honest people allowed to trespass on my
one foot of land there probably probably
not I don't know you put my fence around
it yeah you could you could put a tree
as long as it doesn't grow that big it's
a square that actually would be really
cool to put a fence around it and like I
keep outside yeah we talked about this
before like do you get do you get the
air rights too like how high up and do
you get the mineral rights like you you
bring on a truck it just goes straight
down like three miles through your one
square foot you just have a Gatling gun
that shoots into the sky
yeah okay and about stupid people voting
it is a problem yeah what do you do you
know why I don't vote
that's a good right sure I get ahead of
it yeah
we could put Biden and fetterman in yeah
that's true I want to meet betterment
voters though I really do I want to meet
the people they actually just like him
I'm just imagining like going to the the
town he was mayor of and it's just
literally everyone looks like it's the
same it's overall six foot five bald
with a bulge on their neck the women
look like him the men look like it yeah
the same radiation water has turned them
all into the same guy have you played
Fallout 3 yes so you know the super
mutants they're all basically identical
that's true all right well people who
know the game are like that's anything
right even the women Yeah so basically
in the game like the male and female
super mutants are just big Frankenstein
looking monsters yes yeah it's
incredible yes that's the that's the
better man
so uh what should we do Starship
Troopers service guarantee citizenship
uh I do tests
I don't know look those can be wrong
and it's not so much about it was like
mine was low I want to redo I don't
think 40 it's low you can look I know
people you can open Tupperware I know
people with high IQs you give them a
puzzle they'll solve it you ask them did
Joe Biden engage in a quid pro quo they
say no so like IQ isn't really
no I'm not being serious about that but
I think it all comes down to the media
though it comes down to them talking
about like Mike Johnson is that what
you're driving
about ligma and Johnson and that most
people aren't that stupid but it's what
they're being fed so I think they are
that stupid though
like that lady is that stupid like she
has to talk about it and just was like I
looked at that for two seconds and was
like yeah it's ligma and Johnson
and then she went into this a piece on
it it never occurred her it's crazy no
she's like okay so lick my Johnson
should guys like go on but the other guy
might have known him was just Bobby
Suave we've had him on the show before
and I'm just like I don't understand why
didn't rob a meet Robbie immediately go
like are you talking about literally
yeah
he's usually good too he might have done
it on purpose he's like he's like he's a
um he's of the libertarian sect that
somehow often is like pro-government I
guess that's such a weird yeah
bipolar way of life yeah that's enough
yeah yeah it doesn't make sense yeah I
don't know it's it's it's you know he
often has takes that are like in line
with the establishment and people are
like what are you talking about like you
know but I I think it's like whatever
the libertarian group was before the
music caucus took over the Mesa skies
are more pragmatic before that I think
they call them like the pragmatist or
something and they're typically just
like
I don't know libertarian even if it
supports an establishment narrative or
something can we make ligma Johnson a
lord yeah Lord to make yeah wow can we
have lady ligma Johnson there you go
yeah
lady ligma and Lord Johnson yeah we
could have yeah Lord ligma Johnson and
Lady Lingus well I can only say right
now I'm pretty sure they're very happy
they sponsored the show because like
they're probably getting dozens of
orders for ligmans
they just own a giant part of Scotland
now
well that's the ligman Johnson Forest so
so there's
[Laughter]
right now there's 48 000 people watching
and I'm
48 000 square feet of Lake Lord Lake
Lord Johnson owned land in Scotland no
one I'm not discouraging this at all I
want to see the land first I want to
make sure it's real first but other
otherwise you know there's there's a lot
of other candidates that we could go
with you know there's there's Willie
stroker uh there's uh Harry you know
last name Cox so we could keep going
here uh but my favorite thing one of my
favorite things was was a skit was it
was a skit by Australian comedians that
booked the ticket
um and they booked it for a guy named
Terry last name wrist and and a second
passenger was called Al and then the
last name was Keda and they literally
missed their flight so over over the the
the speakers in the entire airport like
excuse me we're looking for a Terry
wrist and Mr Al-Qaeda to please go to
gate 14. you're about to miss your
flight Mr Terry risk and Al Qaeda please
come to Gate 14 you're about to miss
your
hilarious hilarious uh skit idea by
comedians there I forgot exactly who the
group was uh but they were they were
like absolute Geniuses they also faked
the motorcade
um so it would try to remember it would
be cool actually like even if you know
it wasn't the lordship thing that we
just got like 100 000 people to pitch in
10 bucks to buy a forest and create the
ligma Johnson I'm in we should do it we
should start the ligma Johnson
foundation and have Lego Johnson
everywhere can we seriously can we save
an animal and then have like an anteater
and it'll be the ligma Johnson
[Laughter]
okay we should set up a crowd fund I
mean just use the money to buy property
buildings donate to a hospital the ligma
Johnson Wings
this is we're talking about stupid
people voting and we're sitting here
like who we're going to name stuff like
Mitchell
it would be great though if this went
too far
I agree I absolutely agree we gotta have
the small victories you know exactly
everything's doomed everything's
horrible and you know but but at least
we get to have ligma Johnson I
I will uh what if there's someone's
someone who actually is named ligma
Johnson and he's like listening to this
and he's just like guys it's been a hard
Road for me why don't we just why don't
we just start a new political party
right maybe maybe uh maybe we need to
make like some products you know an
energy drink yeah look at my Johnsons
yeah like look at my Johnson's uh
underwear I don't even be creative about
it just gas station
um Dr ligma Johnson's Vitality formula
testosterone yeah and then we'll like
we'll put a fake thing on it where it's
like in 1803 Dr ligma Johnson created
this you know formula drink to
revitalize men yep and grow your hair
back and it'll give you a nice uh
package
it's an extension this is very important
news recovering today I guess I hope
everybody knows that this is all going
to be real this is exactly what they
covered though Tim they did this is the
news they cover and speaking of covers
condoms ligma Johnson oh that's not a
bad idea flavors
what's what's the what's the least
appropriate product we could make that's
like shouldn't be named ligma Johnson
ice cream
pacifiers ice cream yeah yeah
I was going to say lollipops but man you
take it to another level Jesus that is a
good one though can we start a company
called ligma and Johnson and then just
basically whatever we name the product
it'll say under it you know ligma
Johnson products
yeah you know and like it'll be like a
cursive l and a cursive J yeah okay
parody on Johnson and Johnson you're
hearing it's sued by Johnson and Johnson
yeah we're just uh it's a vaccine if
you're like what's it a four I don't
know I I really like the idea of like
creating a forest preserve and then
people go on Google and they zoom in
like it's going to be 200 years later
and there's going to be some dude
driving around with his wife and they're
like let's go to a park and they pull up
their map app in their virtual space or
whatever it is and they're like oh ligma
Johnson Lookout and then they're gonna
pull up and they're gonna be like what a
great View and they're you know they're
going to look up on on whatever the
future Wikipedia is like the history of
ligma John it's like named because a
bunch of people on a podcast rallied a
bunch of people to take an internet meme
about looking someone's
genitals and turning it into a property
and they did but in the year like 3050
it'll be like the most quaint story
imaginable because everybody's just
garbage
I think a more practical idea
um I was gonna say something
inappropriate but but would actually be
maybe just uh a journalism award you get
the ligma Johnson journalism award for
actually getting things right and done
not being as ridiculous and dumb as ten
dollars oh that's a good point yeah I
like that exactly turn it yeah twist it
so so instead of standing for some you
know ignorant corporate media trash you
actually support rural journalism and
she has to present it to you
until the day she dies now what's the
statue going to be that's the real
question so it'll be on Like a Rolling
Stone logo the ligma Johnson Award for
outstanding performance in the field of
Excellence yes I like it yeah there you
go and uh imperfection it comes it comes
with a ten thousand dollar cash prize
and the reason for that is who would say
no like you get up on if you get up on
stage and accept the award and give a
speech we will write you a check
congratulations I like it and then that
okay maybe a thousand dollars I don't
actually give them money yeah so like a
thousand dollars then a percentage of
that has to go to fund a forest called
ligma Johnson
how many bad journalists would be like
well I do want the money well you
probably have Brian Stelzer every year
no I mean he got fired so oh that's true
he's at Harvard yeah he's not a
journalist he's at Harvard yeah they
took him to Harvard I guess he teaches
class and how not to be gay in public
well they they they uh he teaches people
how to be bad at his job I guess yeah
it's kind of amazing that you can be
fired and get a job at Harvard it is
amazing yeah it's probably because you
know not good for whatever the world is
now
good for him I guess uh you're kind of a
Croc guy thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time